SPEAKER: It's officially
week seven of "Google Cloud
Next" on air, which
means we're focusing
on application modernization.
I'm Stephanie Wong, and
welcome to This Week in Cloud,
where we're taking a sneak
peek at this week's content.
Week 7 is all about
application modernization.
And we all know
that phrase means
something different to
pretty much everyone.
So this week, we've got
five tracks of content,
each packed with sessions.
Whether you want to learn more
about containers, serverless,
app development, cost
management, or ops and SRE,
you're bound to
find something you
like in this session catalog.
So take the time
to browse this week
and add interesting sessions
to your playlist, where
you can watch them on demand.
This week, we're
shining the spotlight
on serverless functions,
which demonstrates
how to use Cloud
Functions to create
standalone functions that
can respond to cloud events
without the need
to manage a server.
And if you're looking
for inspiration
on the possibilities of
functions as a service,
you'll enjoy IKEA's
firsthand account
of how they used Cloud Functions
to create complex applications
and workflows.
I added enhancing
collaboration to my playlist,
because I like the
idea of using Python
to bring my GCP functions into
a convenient place like Google
Sheets.
By creating custom
functions, I can
make it easy for
anyone in the company
to use the GCP
solutions I build.
So if you want to learn more
about how Python can bridge
GCP and Google Sheets to
enhance collaboration,
then be sure to add this
one to your playlist.
Finally, our team is so excited
to be hosting the developer
keynote.
You can hear directly from
the VP of developer relations,
and then stay tuned
for demos from some
of my favorite co-workers.
We look forward to
the dev keynotes.
Because seeing what is possible
with GCP is always inspiring.
And we hope you'll leave this
keynote with your mind spinning
with ideas.
To add these sessions to
your digital playlist,
check out the link.
Any thoughts or ideas?
Leave us a comment, or
tweet us using the hashtag
#googlecloudnext.
And we'll see you in the cloud.